[Music]
hi i'm pretty mystery i'm a chef author
and activist and today i'm going to be
taste testing
some grocery store instant indian meals
the thing i love the most about
indian food is the pow of the different
spices like i'm a libra and so balance
is really important to me
when i'm making a masala i'm thinking
about the sweet
salty spicy tangy
etc there is a fine balance when it all
works
that just evens out all of those
different sort of powerful flavors
[Music]
nice and chunky for how tangy
it the aroma is i'm expecting more
sort of acid but it's actually just kind
of creamy
and spicy for like a you know middle of
the road indian restaurant i don't think
you would get
anything that much better than this i
feel like it you know i would want to
add a little more salt and lemon juice
maybe some fresh cilantro i think out of
five stars i would give this
doll probably three and a quarter three
and a half
i feel like this is something i could
add a little bit more spice to
and a little more salt and lemon juice
and i would be perfectly happy with it
quite honestly
it looks like a chicken curry i would
get
like in an airplane let's go rice and
sauce first just to kind of get a
rice is very sticky a little mushy
kind of textureless the only spice
i really get is black pepper texture of
the chicken
is very it's not tough it's a little
stringy
i don't really get any indian flavor at
all it just
kind of tastes like braised chicken in
tomato sauce
i would give this half a star texturally
it's challenged boiled chicken
sticky um kind of mushy rice
it definitely needs salt and acid but it
also needs just some sort of nuanced
spice to think like if i close my eyes
and somebody gave this to me
and told me it was like some italian
chicken i'd be like okay
full disclosure i have met sookie and
her whole family
they're very nice people i am excited to
try this because i love samosas who
doesn't love samosas look at that it's
crispy
oh look at brown let's see here
the pastry is quite good the interior so
far i get
more uh nuanced spice but it still feels
like it's lacking in salt but let's
maybe
try dipping it in the chutney and see if
that helps with the salt
i feel like someone who is spice averse
would probably love this
i would give the chicken chicken masala
samosas
two and a quarter stars i'm really
wanting more salt and spice the texture
is great
the pastry is fantastic i feel like i
want
more pow
all right it actually smells quite good
this is
also sookies but this is chicken chicken
masala with
naan bread it's called on the box which
is redundant
but i understand trying to meet your
customer where they're at
let's see i don't want to burn my tongue
flavor you get a lot of clove cinnamon
definitely the fenugreek ginger i would
say the biggest issue i have right now
is just that it really needs more salt
let's try some rice now the rice also
i'll give you a look at that
it looks a lot um more like separate
grains as opposed to
the signature select that sort of look
like kind of mushy
sticky texturally so far i feel like
this is the best thing we've had let's
try the naan
again got some nice browning on the back
there you can see
i love naan now bread in a microwave is
gonna be chewy so there's nothing crispy
about this like a regular naan that you
get out of its own door it'd be like
crisp on the edges and soft
this is a little bit more like soft and
chewy just kind of get the
[Music]
chewy if i got this naan in here i would
just throw it in the toaster
i think i would give this one because of
the lack of salt
and spice i'm gonna go three and a half
the variety of starches the bread and
the rice
i think is a bonus if you were to toast
the naan i think you'd get probably
the best sort of you know grocery store
non-experience
the curry just needs to be boosted a
little bit i think if you
are buying these meals and you like them
and you want to
go a little bit deeper in your enjoyment
or appreciation or understanding of
indian cuisine i would definitely say
go to your local indian restaurant
because even if it's mediocre it's
probably going to be
10 times better than anything i just
[Music]
tasted
[Music]
you